this is about you know relying on the
citizens capacity to to act together and
emerge stronger out of each and every
crisis
combines so many factors that are really
unique that it's not easy to say the one
that is the most important also not
possible to say that one sector is most
influenced but going back to your
question we should start with inflation
because inflation is very evil and
that's why it's really so important to
get inflation under control those
businesses that have high consumption of
energies will be sooner or later
affected inflation is such a high
that the income of people the wages or
other income is just declining the real
income is declining so obviously people
have less money to spend they need to
save more money to have money to pay
electricity bills to buy the foods that
is more expensive the government should
provide the support for businesses for
household but at the same time we should
have in mind that if support will be
strong enough inflation will stay high
and inflation is very evil we need to
get inflation down
[Music]
for the vulnerable people right now the
choice would be or it already is in
between paying the bills or ensuring a
proper meal for their children
so what we are seeing right now is a
huge pressure on the have-nots of our
society of the ones that already were
really badly hit during the pandemic and
right now again they are suffering
because of this particular crisis we see
that the vulnerable people are affected
but we also see that categories of uh
you know medium income uh population
have been started to to to fall towards
the vulnerability so this is indeed an
important social crisis after all
we do have a an issue here that is very
important so if we will invest in this
kind of Energy Efficiency projects in
helping diminishing the bills and then
dependence on electricity
um this would mean that we we will be
able to do two things at the same time
on one hand to look at our ambition here
with European level to push the green
transition to to be uh you know top-end
technologies that that would help us and
at the same time to have our citizens
less dependent on this kind of
volatility related to energy and and so
on in terms of the smes very very click
on this one it's also very important to
create a safety net so that if we have
right now issues in terms of the
capacity available of energy we will be
able to put forward schemes such as the
ones using pandemic so that if there
will be temporary close Downs I mean at
least we will be able to react
immediately and have the necessary
resources and we have this kind of tools
at European level helped tremendously
the business sector during the pandemic
and these are as part of the lessons
learned that we can use right now most
economists would say try to be as
targeted as possible help the vulnerable
swans I guess it's even time to support
the lower mid income people because they
are suffering too but try to avoid very
very broad supportive measures that are
expensive for the fiscal and also has
more potential to create to create
inflation
it will take time before we get out from
high inflation
but we really should not extend this
period for longer than necessary
obviously the work of the central bank
is very delicate because it's not only
getting from very high inflation maybe
even to negative inflation it's about
the landing at the zone of low inflation
this is very delicate the job and this
would be way how to reduce the cost of
this inflation
foreign
resilience plans are right right now
starting to to kick in and have their
role repower is just going directly
targeting citizens and then you have all
the other measures that are going to
come up with investments in increasing
energy Supply reducing demand and this
would be the way in which Europe is
reacting in March if you were to ask
anyone here
if he can handle without Russian gas the
reply would be no because we were 40
depending on the gas now the Russian gas
is almost gone and we know that we will
handle that EU policy shouldn't be about
you know spreading helicopter money and
you know populist promises or
nationalist things that we need to to go
back to our turf this is about you know
relying on the citizens capacity to to
act together and and to to emerge
stronger out of each and every crisis